what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with God loves man
kills again this is this is one of my
favorite stories guys I mean I love God
loves man kills and a lot of guys really
seem to enjoy to this old style of
writing very very soap opera like
character focus you know he writes
action but it was focused more on the
nature of the characters themselves now
here's the thing in the aftermath of the
the death of Xavier or at least of the
perceived death of Xavier Cyclops and
storm um this sends the x-men in a lot
of ways into disarray now this is one of
the important things also bear in mind
too when it came to how the x-men were
done by Claremont one of the things that
he established very very early on is
that they were very much
autonomous they did not rely explicitly
on Xavier to get their orders and in
fact this is kind of what the x-men had
been training for when Claremont wrote
these stories the idea was there will
come a time eventually when Xavier is
killed or Xavier is removed from the
landscape and the x-men have to be able
to know how to function accordingly now
the other half of this is Kitty Pryde
now Kitty Pryde as a character we talked
about her a little bit you know in the
the previous videos but I want to focus
a little bit more on her in this one
Kitty Pryde when she was brought into
the x-men
she was really designed to be like the
young readers kind of entry way into the
x-men mythos and what I mean by that is
Claremont was very very good at writing
characters in such a way to where they
were relatable and so when you looked at
Wolverine he was obviously a character
who had been written in such a way that
he'd been around for a long time like
for quite some time and he'd seen and
done a lot of things and so with that
having been the case and it kind of
turned into okay so like he's the guy we
can follow to kind of get like the
backstory of what's going on with
regards to like what's been happening
around the planet his backstory was
ambiguous as health but with regards to
to what was going on behind the scenes
that was kind of a way to feed into that
you looked at Cyclops and it was like
okay what if we were like the leader of
the team Xavier was the teacher Jean
Grey was well she was the cheerleader
more or less under understand Lee and
Jack Kirby and then she became the one
who was sort of coming into her own
under Claremont kind of you know rising
in and becoming something a little more
prominent sort of shooting up in the
ranks but Kitty Pryde was the one who
was like if you're brand new to x-men
then like Kitty Pryde the character you
follow because she was brand new to the
x-men she was just some young wide-eyed
kid who was brought onto the team and
she was learning what it meant to be an
x-man as she fought alongside the x-men
and so she was learning about her powers
but she was also learning what it meant
to become a woman when she was being
taught these various things from storm
and and Stevie Ray and so on and so
forth
her care to receive a lot of emphasis in
the fact that she was experienced
a lot of tough times at a very young age
she was going through like all the
puberty stages that young kids go
through at the same time she was falling
in love she was she had a huge thing for
four Colossus and she was kind of
learning her place in the bigger picture
and so the idea of Professor X and
Cyclops and storm being killed is really
kind of like a huge thing for her
because really like the mentor she's
been alerted that she's been learning
from are really like perishing around
her and so it's kind of a big thing
because it's like yes this is the price
we pay for being an x-man but it's not
something that you're really prepared
for even when it happens now as she's
going through a kind of musing to
herself where she's talking to like
Illyana Rasputin this the younger sister
of Colossus she really just kind of goes
off on her own does her own thinking and
then comes across was essentially like a
spy camera belonging to the purifiers
and again the purifiers are spying on
the x-men and have been for quite some
time and so at this point we shift over
to Wolverine and we shift over to
Colossus now this is one of the big
things about how Wolverine was written
back him it's something that you don't
really see anymore with his character
Wolverine was written as a character
where it were again you know Chris come
outside and said this guy's been around
for a long time when Wolverine was part
of Team X when he was part of that black
ops wet work team working for the CIA I
mean they they took out political
officials they took out political rivals
they took they they toppled governments
they did all kinds of things and so
Wolverine became very very very very
good at staging crime scenes and so when
he goes over here with Colossus and he
starts sniffing around and he starts
looking at what's going on
right off the bat he says this is not
what it looks like they weren't killed
they were taken from here and one of the
big questions this ass is how do you
know this is like one I've staged enough
crime scenes in my life to know what a
fake crime scene looks at but not only
that the bodies they found here are not
the bodies of of storm in Cyclops and
Xavier because they don't smell the same
the nose nose
the Cintas off at the same time you've
got Wolverine kind of looking around the
area kind of putting his his blackops
experience to use really like his
longevity to use you've got Nightcrawler
who's analyzing everything and they come
up on the idea there are guys who were
sitting in this car over there and
they're basically watching this they're
watching the crime scene there they're
looking to see what happens and so those
guys have to be in on it and that's when
Wolverine kind of picks up on the idea
they're involved in this somehow and so
you end up having Nightcrawler who shows
up you have Wolverine who dons a costume
we've got Colossus who arrives and they
try to run them over and one of the one
of the girls is basically taking you
know one of the folks is taken out the
car explodes in a fiery crash and like
two of the guys are rescued now this is
one of the things that Claremont was
that he was big on he never shied away
from killing people he never shied away
from from like the x-men basically
killing people they wouldn't do it out
of malice the actions wouldn't just be
like you know what I'm tired of you and
then just kill you didn't really see it
all that often it would be one of these
things were like it was just collateral
damage but it but it really went towards
focusing on the x-men themselves because
then it's like has a team that's
basically a peacekeeping group how do
they handle like by their own action
getting someone killed it went really
really really well in hand with
everything that was going on in terms of
focusing on like the nature of the
character development there were in turn
a couple of these guys are rescued from
this fire you end up having magneto who
steps in who literally like dismantled
their suits and turns them into cocoons
of sorts and locks them in now right off
the bat the x1 are just like bad guy and
they respond by intending to take out
magneto but man you don't respond by
saying I'm not here as an enemy I'm here
as an ally now this is important because
again this goes into the nature of
Magneto becoming somewhat of a good guy
that's one of the cool things about this
is he's you know the way he's drawn the
way he speaks he's a guy that comes to
this with experience he's made to be
very very human not some guy who's like
I have magnetism powers you know that's
that's not really how he was done back
then magneto is a guy who hates humans
but in this one in one of these
instances is it's kind of like the enemy
of my enemy is my friend there is a
group out there that is hunting down
mutants mercilessly they're killing them
everywhere they find them and they're
not taking prisoners or do no quarters
being offered here and so it's really
kind of like a war on mutant kind
magneto becomes an ally of the x-men and
it is kind of cool the way this whole
thing plays out because then you end up
having a Kitty Pryde who kind of Stow's
away you know when when these they're
you know back at the Xavier Institute
when these purifiers come back to pick
up their camera a kitty pryde sort of
Stow's away but the purifiers are ready
for them and that's one of the things to
bear in mind you know for her she's
inexperienced if this had been like
Colossus if it had been especially if
Cyclops were here it would have been a
more diplomatic approach I mean
diplomatic in so far probably more
stealthy approach is a better better
word he used it would have been like we
can't go in guns blazing they have to be
prepared for us I mean if they were to
see if they were able to successfully
capture
Xavier and Cyclops and storm they had to
have been prepared for us and if they
were prepared for us it means they
understand how our powers work and they
know how we function as a team Kitty
Pryde is not that well-versed she just
kind of shows up she tries to stow away
and you know immediately she's captured
by by the purifiers and so while they're
basically leaving with Kitty Pryde you
end up having the x-men who were showing
up with the other purifiers now
this is a really really cool moment here
because when it comes to this kind of
situation
Claremont again focused on the darker
side of the x-men the fact that they
were willing to do things that would
tote the line of what it meant to be a
good guy and sometimes just walk across
it entirely when you're Wolfe rain and
you've been in the trenches and you've
done some pretty shady things you don't
really shy away from saying like hey
we're probably gonna have to kill some
folks we're gonna have to get our hands
dirty
he doesn't mind doing that it's the
nature of what he does and so we're
these purifiers kind of refused to talk
where they say like we're not worried
about this will rain for kind of puffs
his claws but in the end of the day they
know it's taunting cuz all Wolverine can
really do is like kill them it's the
nature of what he does I mean you know
he's kind of pops his claws and he can
scratch them a little bit but with that
a mantium Wolverine doesn't really have
a whole lot of finesse it's just kind of
like I'm going to slash you and I'm
gonna kill you and that's really it
there's not a whole lot he can do here
he's not nuanced and so instead when
Wolverine kind of tries to torture them
and and LU they they hold their guns
Magneto's response is we have to go to
the darker side of things here we have
to do some bad things and so let me be
the bad guy who does bad things and so
what what magneto basically does here he
literally pulls apart the metal cocoons
that he wrapped these guys in and starts
put it like literally entering them into
their bodies it's like putting bamboo
reeds under their fingernails he's
torturing them he's torturing them for
information and and where the other
x-men look on and they're just kind of
like is this really something that we
should do well Ray's response is
absolutely this is absolutely what we
need to do these guys cannot be reasoned
with you cannot get them to talk beer
will not work the only thing that will
answer to is pain pain in the most
extreme form and it's literally just
shards of metal being twisted through
their physical bodies you know leaving
them in an in a state where they'll say
anything to make the pain stop and as
one of these crazy things magneto is
well known to the purifiers he's well
known as a guy who will do whatever it
takes in order to get the information
that he wants and in this instance
instead of like bombarding him with
psychic torture physical pain is what's
the worst because psychic torture is you
just kind of like screwing up the scream
of a person's mind and in a lot of ways
it can be worst but physical pain from
the master of magnetism sliding you know
shards of metal into your body like just
in and out of your body it's the most
extreme form of pain that they could
possibly imagine and so they'll tell the
truth because what this means is that if
they don't the pain will keep coming
they'll keep them here and then in turn
go and investigate their information and
if their information cut proves to be
false they'll come right back and the
pain will be worse the second time
around that it was the first because not
only the
want the information they're all so
pissed off this guy lied so again it's
it's pretty dark and is pretty twisted
but it's the nature of things but I will
say this if you think this is dark and
twisted at the moment wait until you see
where they do to Xavier in the next
video the purify like William Stryker
is cold-blooded they absolutely torture
Charles Xavier it is one of the most
most crazy things that you could
possibly imagine but without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are know here two comments
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob pork
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I miss these
old-style x-men stories and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you